Alright, so I want to make a pie chart showing the distribution of musical
genres, so I made a new report on bands, and I added this genre column.
>> Right.
>> I'm going to have to make it a summary.
>> Yep.
>> And I want to group by genre, right? Oh, okay, I didn't mean to do that.
>> It's okay.
>> It's okay. And you will probably want to
show, I'm mean if this were a real report.
Other fields about the bands that are playing. I would assume.
>> Okay.
>> So drag a few of those guys in there too.
>> So I'm going to add my chart. going to make
it a pie chart. Values will be record count.
>> Yep
>> The wedges will be genre.
>> Just knows.
>> This is really good.
>> Oh, and then they will hover and
you said you wanted to show percentages, right?
>> Yeah.
Very cool. And then I'm just going to run the report, or save
it first to run the report and then add it to my dashboard.
>> Sounds good.
>> And Sam, I'm sorry, but it looks like we're only going
to have 6% of the bands at our festival will be Bossa Nova.
>> That sounds about right.
[LAUGH]
>> 30% rock, 20% electronic quite a bit
of reggae and even 14% salsa. Pretty cool.